and so if you look at this game so this
is the way a Calabasas looked the retail
price was you know just under $35 my
royalties was about $5 apiece and they
sold 30,000 copies so we do that math
that's $150,000 that I got paid as a
high school senior for seven weeks of
afterschool time at a time when my
father's income as an astronaut was
$65,000 a year so I doubled or tripled
my dad's income with some after-school
time and so that's what started it by
the way
it's been downhill ever since video
games are always morphing as technology
as a medium and as a form of
entertainment they are in a constant
state of change yet they are still very
young and because of this there are
still people around who have seen them
evolve up close all the way from their
inception to the shape they take today
Richard Garriott is one of those people
his name now rests on the periphery of
the video game lexicon but his influence
is everywhere he created the first
Ultima in 1981 in the series later set
precedents for things we take for
granted today tile graphics party based
combat ethical decisions and the use of
a larger narrative around the mechanics
of a game he worked on Ultima Online a
title that defined and popularized
online multiplayer RPGs
[Music]
he also paved the way for immersive Sims
games that blend first-person mechanics
and role-playing systems in a cohesive
world Garrett's work influenced young
developers who grew up to make games
today Harvey Smith and raphaël
colantonio are two such people in
several cases they worked with Gary on
immersive Sims the kind of game they all
shared a passion for and with titles
such as arcs fate Tallis Dark Messiah of
Might and Magic
dishonored dishonor to and prey arcane
is seen as the torchbearer of modern
immersive Sims to understand the state
of the genre today we traveled a few
miles from our cannes austin studio to
speak to Richard Garriott whose
experience in the industry predates most
developers around today
[Music]
oh you know if you look back to the
earliest days some of the stuff that's
directly behind me
the machines were very primitive but you
also did it mostly by your stuff you
work alone you know in these early games
I was the artist to the greeted head art
you know the designer of the program or
the writer you know whatever it was
including often making the packaging and
shipping it and copying the discs at
home to put in the bags you know that
was did it all and there was sort of
this so kind of almost I would say
Golden Age this is real Renaissance
especially in the genre of role-playing
that I think is is exemplified by the
heydays of origin when people like
myself had the opportunity to work with
Warren Duck church Paul Neurath and
raphaël colantonio many are if not most
of us had actually done some Solo made
games independently as an individual but
then we began to you know not not only
build larger teams but work often in
collaboration with each other to kind of
really push the art form in a
significant way I would at least try to
tribe myself and I think the other folks
are to Tolkien style developers and I
use that term in that you know Tolkien
would write back stories and histories
and think about his worlds in great
depth long before we ever wrote the
final story and you can feel that you
can feel that when you go when you read
a Tolkien book you can feel that this
guy really does know what's around every
boulder and under every Creek in the
history of every video ruin that's in
the setting cities created once you
figure out what your reality does
consistently then you develop a plot
that leads you through exploring that
reality one of my game design principles
that I encourage we're here within our
own team is not that it has to be a
simulation of true reality it just has
to be consistent and it has to be
logical and and the example I would give
is lissa foes right now you and me we're
in this building the buildings on fire
and we have to get out or we're in
trouble of course first thing we're
traitors go to the door let's suppose
the doors locked
well if the doors locked we might notice
the hinges in this case are on the
inside so it might knock those out with
the screws
and then can take the door off well if
that doesn't work well I was glass
beside those we cried break through the
glass well if that was the wire kind of
glass the next I might think of is this
an acoustic drop ceiling we might be
able to pop off a tile and go over
unless that's one of the fire wall
pieces in which case we might not then
we go okay how about an exterior window
and but if the drop is too far then we
go it's okay it's a sheetrock wall let's
break through the wall there's this
deductive process that you go through
because we are familiar with the
consistent implementation of reality and
so one of the things that I'm quite
quite big on and the games we create is
don't mislead players to thinking of you
know to think that something might work
and don't deliver it working and
conversely you know if players do think
of a way that should logically work
let's make sure that we fulfilled that
this in particular sings to me I mean I
use this example all the time I don't
know if I got it from Europe but you see
a telephone on it I put a telephone on a
desk if it's just a prop you should be
able to use it you know if there's a
cannon you should be able to use it and
the importance of simulation as a design
tool very very big the farther back in
gaming history you look the more you see
it is purely game mechanics and art that
sell and by the way you do need really
great game mechanics and it absolutely
up to have great art so I'm not knocking
either one of those those are
foundationally really important but a
great story I get reason to be there is
also profoundly important
[Music]
and and I think that's what games need
to do is push people out of their
comfort zones hold a mirror up to their
closely held beliefs and help them grow
as individuals you know I got in as many
do into the game industry about the age
of 19 is when I published you know my
first game I've been making a few on my
own ahead of that and while that is not
unusual what was unusual is there was no
one before me that you know there were
two or three other 19 year-olds like me
who got in at about the same time as I
did you know plus or minus a couple
years but pretty much through my whole
career I've been the oldest guy in the
industry and you know when you're 19 and
20 and 25 that doesn't seem like that
big a deal other than just to note that
hey everybody's the new kids are getting
in and so the guiness using bigger but
now at the age of 55 it's actually kind
of this amazing feeling to just go back
and go you know like the word avatar you
know most people who are graduating
schools don't know where the word avatar
came from was came from right there
you know 3d graphics in a role-playing
game right here no boxes right there
you know you mean it's all all this sort
of stuff you know happened not only
happen in my lifetime but I've had the
chance to participate in many of those
incremental steps we are sharing pieces
of fiction we're sharing artifacts
within our games and we're all kind of
doing pieces of omage to the things
we've done in the past so that our the
the people that do know where we've come
from can feel that sense of continuity
and feel that sense of the depth of the
truth of this reality simulation we're
doing that goes back frankly through the
entire span of gaming Garriott's
prolific career in video games allowed
him other pursuits as well you know I've
done really well in gaming but I've
blown it all on space he took part in
the first zero-g wedding he's garnered
fame for being a self-funded astronaut
boarding the International Space Station
in October of 2008 35 years after his
father did the same this is richard
garriott coming to you from the
International Space Station
but today Garriott continues working on
games his current project is shrouded
the avatar a spiritual successor to the
Ultima series that molded RPGs all those
years ago it's a continuation of the
work he did alongside those developers
in the 80s and 90s people who shared a
passion for a certain kind of game
that back then was ahead of its time in
the end though Gary its history eclectic
and accomplished as it is only fills out
one side of the story and that brings us
here to the other side on the outskirts
of Austin to the place where another
immersive sim is being made and across
the street in a house lined with
memorabilia of a story life
we found Warren Spector you know I
really have two thousand boys next door
oh yes I do I have ten thousand books
all of them catalogued amazingly enough
over at the library which is up the
street where we're working on System
Shock 3 right now and I've got this is
the graphic novels and comic book
section and then over in the house I
live in next door about 3,000 film and
television would like Garriott spectres
name is faded from the video game
industry foreground in recent years but
like Garriott spectres influence can
still be seen everywhere
I am a 33-year veteran of game
development and it kind of blows my mind
when I think about that someday you will
all be 33-year veterans and wondering
where the time went
especially in the work of Arkane Studios
Bethesda and irrational games it's also
present in Metal Gear Solid 5 and The
Legend of Zelda breath of a wild games
that stress emergent gameplay over
tightly scripted set peace moments this
threat of emergent gameplay runs through
origin systems where Spectre worked as a
producer on several of chariots Altima
games as well as System Shock and Ultima
Underworld hacker begins unauthorized
entry into the trioptimum corporate
network he would later become general
manager at Looking Glass Austin where he
oversaw the early stages of thief before
he began his seminal work on Deus Ex
that ion storm let it spill over to the
schools and churches let the bodies pile
up in the streets in the end they'll
take us to save them when I das
Interactive closed ion storm Spector
moved on to form Junction point studios
the team behind Epic Mickey it was such
an amazing experience working with guys
like Paul Neurath and Doug Church and
and Tim's tell Mac and and Harvey Smith
it was we were all you know kind of
young punks how to change the world and
you know we had these ideas that we just
needed to explore it was it wasn't like
we wanted to or we kind of thought ya
might be cool it was a need you know we
had no choice you know we did have an
influence we had an influence on other
developers which was really part of the
point for me when I was working on Deus
Ex I I wanted I shouldn't say this out
loud but I wanted a shame other
developers so they could never make the
kinds of games that they were making
again and I think we did have that kind
of influence so you just see more people
doing it there's that the tools are much
better than the simulation in system
shock was not deep let's just say and in
the the Ultima games it was not deep we
did the best we could for the time but
now you can build you know physics
simulations and tools that are just
immensely powerful and so players can
get deeper into the experience and also
I think gamers have matured you know
there's this myth that games are just
for kids that's never been true
you know they've grown up on games like
System Shock and underworld
even as X they grew up with that kind of
game their expectations change they're
tired I think of games that are tight
that I was going to say they're tired of
games that were tightly scripted there's
still a huge market for for games that
are incredibly tightly scripted but I
think a lot of players just want more
they
or control them their experience welcome
back to Citadel station we hope your
somnolent healing stage went well today
is the sixth day of November year 207 -
you are currently in the healing Suites
located on the first level as mixed
feelings about the whole explosion of
immersive simulation and emergent
gameplay on the one hand I'm thrilled
about it because it means I have more
games to play and I really have always
believed that you know if you're going
to honor a medium and grow a medium and
mature a medium you kind of have to do
what it does that no other medium can do
and emergent gameplay and shared
authorship is is what we do that no
other medium can do movies can't do it
books can't do it opera can't do it you
know we do that on the one hand I'm
thrilled that that people have finally
caught on you know I mean you look at
the math ESDA games now you look at what
irrational was doing you look at what
our caine is doing you look at at what
Bioware is doing and you see the roots
are in the work that origin and
lookingglass and later ion storm
injunction point we're doing you can see
the influence maybe I guess my ego is
out of control I don't know but but I
can see the influence and I'm really
excited about that and then there's on
the other hand this intense frustration
that they get all the credit you know I
mean emergences is kind of a standard
way to think about things in software
development now but when we started
working on these games at origin and
then at Looking Glass no one else was
doing that everybody was just everything
was scripted in games up to that point
and we started playing around with
emergence and games that were designed
to not just encourage or allow but
really really kind of force players to
solve problems in their own ways we
would look at each other and say why
isn't everybody making games like this
this is what games do that no other
medium can do I mean why why is it
everybody doing this and now here it is
you know 20 years later and everybody's
doing it it's kind of cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people expect me to be really
upset that other people are are now
doing this kind of game or especially
Deus Ex man I get asked all the time
aren't you upset that someone else is
making deus ex games as I know I the
idea that we were part of something
bigger than ourselves that you know Deus
Ex has a life of its own beyond me and
beyond the team that's nothing but cool
it's like watching a kid grow up you
know and leave home and become an adult
it's it's nothing but good I'm loving
the fact that you know Steve Gaynor and
Harvey in particular since I worked with
Harvey for so long you know seeing what
he's doing now he's doing way better
than I ever did you know these guys are
are way smarter than we were and like I
said they have better tools it's it's
nothing but but great to see people you
know the the new generation of
developers appreciating and carrying on
the tradition today specters career has
come full circle
he's here in Austin again working on
System Shock 3 with other side
entertainment across the country just
outside of Boston spectres longtime
friend and colleague Paul Neurath is
making underworld ascendant in many ways
they're picking up where they left off
with the games that sparked their
passion for development to begin with
Spectre worked closely with Harvey Smith
on Deus Ex in 2000 before the studio
closed and before Smith joined arcane it
was here where Smith would learn the
intricacies and difficulties of creating
immersive Sims and it only fueled his
creativity in a larger sense Smith's
design sensibilities and passion for
games comes from Specter and the lessons
he passed down it was great having
Harvey on the team Deus Ex would not
have been what it was without Harvey I'm
not sure System Shock would have been
what it was without Harvey you know
Harvey was one of the testers on System
Shock back in the 90s I remember you
know we were we would work pretty crazy
hours that still do but
it was really insane then and I you know
it'd be 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning
and I'd go down to where QA was testing
the game and Harvey would be the last
guy there and wait a minute what's
what's going on everybody went home but
except for Harvey and we would sit there
and we would talk about games and talk
about System Shock and would talk about
immersive simulation cuz I felt like
Warren was more like me in one sense
that that you know film and books you
know we're and pen and paper rpgs was
very important to you and had
transformed your life in some way
and so I really grew a lot in that that
10 months you know and by the end I was
lead tester and you know Warren was
talking about recruiting me into his
producer group I got a real sense of his
design chops yeah not just the quality
but the way he thought about games and
so the first opportunity I had I brought
him into my producer group at origin as
an associate producer the first project
we worked on together was a game called
cyber made
in a week luck eventually Harvey Harvey
wanted to work on a different kind of
game and so I took that bad and he
started working on his own stuff I was
able to put him in a creative leadership
position and saw him do wonderful things
and he's a great charismatic talented
leader so he was able to lead teams and
I knew what kind of games he wanted to
make which was exactly the kind of games
I wanted to make and so I tried to
support him as much as I could you
recognized me in a way that was very
useful to my whole development you know
my boss would come to me and go you know
Warren came by today and he was asking
if he could have you for his next
project and Richard Garriott came by and
he said that are you free to move into
development to do this TD a grunt work
you know and technical design assistant
but which and the programmers refer to
as total dumbass by the way well he left
origin I went off to another company out
on the west coast and I had to get him
back I just had to and so he was
visiting Austin and we went to a Mexican
restaurant and I knew the booth we were
sitting in I knew we were going to make
Deus Ex I needed a lead designer you
know I convinced him to to move back to
Austin to be the lead designer on Deus
Ex he had the situation under control
agent
oh [ __ ] going down how's it been I've
been now working on games for 33 years
in September it'll be 34 years it's been
an amazing adventure I gotta say it's
been a great career you know I hope it
continues to be a great career for many
years to come
you know I dropped out of a ph.d program
to make games and my mother cried for
ten years I swear she just cried
constantly for ten years gave up a great
career in teaching to make games you
know but I've been the luckiest guy in
the world I've gotten to do what I love
I've gotten to work with the most
amazing people I can imagine working
with I've gotten to work on things that
are bigger than me you know that have a
life of their own I look back and I
wouldn't change it then maybe it's
because of how young the medium is or
how constantly it changes but we can
often forget the past where all of this
started and how we got here
Spector and Gary are two such reminders
of those origins their work began in
Austin and Massachusetts and branched
outward across the country to numerous
titles that have become mainstays in the
videogame zeitgeist projects such as
Bioshock half life gone home and the
original Xbox all spawned from those
same roots at Looking Glass and origin
systems developers are always looking
for new ways to push games forward but
it's not happening in a vacuum
people such as Spectre have spent their
careers finding like-minded individuals
learning from them and growing alongside
them along the way they might run into a
Smith or a colantonio
and pass those lessons on and that
brings us back to the present to the
Arkane studios we know today although
the first dishonored was the team's
breakout hit it was only the beginning
of a new chapter in the studio's history
and as they move forward into uncertain
territory they're being forced to
reexamine their identity several times
over
[Music]